It has been said that “Death is not the
greatest of evils: rather, it is to wish to
die when one cannot.”
Imagine you were unable to die, never once
aging for the rest of time.
Sounds like it would be pretty neat, right?
Everybody wants to live forever, but we rarely
ever think about how traumatic it would be
to achieve immortality.
Picture all those future historical events
you would live through.
But think of everyone you would lose as well,
all those loved ones that would grow old and
pass away while you remained still, staying
exactly the same forever, frozen.
If you had finite memory, it would be even
worse.
No matter who you lost, after centuries you
would eventually forget them too, their smiles,
their laughs, every detail of them would be
gone from you, as you carry on living endlessly.
Immortality would likely be a very lonely
path, and nobody is a better example of that
than SCP-1440, otherwise known as The Old
Man from Nowhere.
As the nickname describes, SCP-1440 appears,
at least at first glance, to be a man of unknown
age and ethnicity.
SCP-1440 is currently uncontained, but also
is not considered hostile or actively evil
by the SCP Foundation.
Mostly, he spends his days wandering the wilderness
on his own.
On the few instances he has crossed paths
with the Foundation, when questioned about
his name, or where he was born, the old man
will refuse to answer.
It is not clear if this is because he does
not want to divulge personal information about
his origins, or if he simply doesn’t have
answers to those questions.
Eyewitness accounts have described The Old
Man from Nowhere as looking like an elderly
gentleman, approximately eighty years old.
However, descriptions of him have not changed
at all in the fifty years since SCP-1440’s
existence was first brought to the Foundation’s
attention, with him always being described
as looking the same way without changing.
And there’s only one conclusion we can land
on from there.
SCP-1440 doesn’t age.
So, you may be wondering, is that it?
Is SCP-1440 just an immortal wanderer, a rambling
old man who is destined to keep on living
long after all of us are dead.
Not quite.
In fact, that’s barely the tip of the proverbial
iceberg.
Each time that The Old Man from Nowhere comes
into contact with a human population, or anything
man made at all, the rest of his anomalous
nature is revealed.
Not instantly, since he has to remain in contact
with a population and stay close to them for
a few days.
Only then does this adverse effect on humanity,
and everything connected to it, become more
apparent.
Should SCP-1440 dwell too close to people
and man made structures for any extended period
of time, massively destructive events will
begin to occur nearby.
These events will continue to increase in
size and scale, until everything in the immediate
vicinity of the Old Man is dead and destroyed.
Humans, buildings, vehicles, there is nothing
left around him but total and utter devastation.
All that survives is SCP-1440 himself, along
with the clothes on his back, a sack he carries
over one shoulder, a pack of playing cards,
and the small glass that he keeps on his person
at all times.
Even though he causes disaster on a horrendous
scale wherever he goes, SCP-1440 is not actively
evil.
The Old Man is fully aware of the effect he
has when stationed too close to civilization
for too long, but he doesn't create these
destructive events by choice or out of malice
for human beings.
Death just seems to follow him, whether he
wants it to or not.
And it is for exactly this reason that he
chooses a life of solitude, wandering from
place to place with the intention of avoiding
human contact for as long as he possibly can.
Or at least, that’s his intention, but SCP-1440
is unable to stay away for too long.
The Old Man from Nowhere suffers from a compulsion
to travel in a strange, highly complicated
pattern of movement and despite their best
efforts, the researchers of the SCP Foundation
have been thus far unable to properly analyze
this pattern.
SCP-1440 literally cannot stop himself, he
can’t even provide any useful information
about why he feels so compelled to travel
in such a way, most likely because he is not
even aware of it happening.
But whatever the reason may be, The Old Man
from Nowhere will inevitably travel in his
unpredictable patterns that always lead him
towards civilization, where he will come into
contact with people and ultimately cause their
doom.
It is due to his unintentional, yet highly
destructive capabilities, that SCP-1440 remains
uncontained by the SCP Foundation to this
day.
All previous attempts to contain him have
resulted in catastrophic losses for the Foundation,
both in resources and the lives of personnel.
Even so, the Old Man is far from hostile,
and shows no contempt towards human beings.
He will even willingly and without resistance,
allow himself to be captured and subdued whenever
the Foundation have attempted to contain him,
though he seems to know that it’s only a
matter of time before everything around him
is destroyed and he’s forced to embark on
his wandering path once again.
SCP-1440 was first brought to the attention
of the SCP Foundation over fifty years ago.
During a commute to work, one of the Foundation’s
research staff was approached by an old man
who appeared to be in his eighties and was
asking for her help.
When she asked what he needed help with, the
man told her that he hoped the SCP Foundation
would be able to destroy him.
Not only had he somehow learned the identity
of this Foundation doctor and tracked her
down, but SCP-1440 had sought out the Foundation
so that they could bring an end to his immortal
existence.
Permanently.
The Foundation had the Old Man from Nowhere
brought in for questioning at one of their
secret facilities - a grave mistake.
Before they could even attempt to theorize
a way to terminate SCP-1440, as he’d requested,
the SCP Foundation’s site was completely
obliterated.
Over one hundred personnel were killed, and
the loss of the facility also destroyed six
‘Safe’ and ‘Euclid’ class SCP objects.
Ever since then, any attempt to contain the
Old Man from Nowhere has ended in much the
same way, with hundreds dead, and millions
of dollars worth of property destruction.
Until they have a sure fire way of keeping
SCP-1440 and his destructive power contained,
their best option is to focus on observing
him from a safe distance, and trying to predict
his travel pattern to steer him away from
civilians.
But still, the Foundation has persevered with
capturing SCP-1440, even if only for brief
periods of time.
During this time, they have conducted numerous
interviews, each time learning more and more
about the aloof, elusive immortal and his
various exploits over the centuries.
Few records of these interviews have managed
to survive the destructive power of the Old
Man from Nowhere’s anomalous abilities.
However, there exists one transcript, an interview
from the Foundation’s fourth attempt to
contain SCP-1440, that was logged and saved
to a remote server off site.
Before the interview had begun, SCP-1440’s
arrival to the area had already started to
cause adverse effects on the Foundation’s
staff.
A number of personnel reported experiencing
severe headaches and nausea.
Over the two days that followed, many of the
site’s water purification filters were found
to be malfunctioning.
Shortly after, a hangar at the site collapsed,
killing several Foundation airmen.
Additionally, a member of research personnel
was found to have suffered a total collapse
of both kidneys and lungs simultaneously,
all despite having been in perfect physical
health.
SCP-1440, complying with the Foundation as
he had before, sat down with a doctor to commence
the interview.
The Old Man was quick to praise the SCP Foundation
for their continued efforts to capture and
contain him, even though the previous three
times had all ended catastrophically.
He stated that he now knew the Foundation
could not help him bring an end to his immortality,
and that it was in their best interests to
release him.
SCP-1440 then warned the doctor that The First
Brother was standing behind them.
During previous interviews, the Old Man from
Nowhere had made similar allusions to a group
of brothers, three of them to be precise.
This time, he expanded a little on who these
brothers were.
“Three, Aye.
Different, but one and the same.
All cruel, all vengeful, all capable of holding
a grudge for a long time.
They are the cause of my misfortune, and therefore
the cause of yours.”
It was at that moment that SCP-1440 seemed
to notice something standing behind the doctor
interviewing him, and warned that the Second
Brother had now joined the first.
He claimed time was running out and that the
Foundation needed to release him for their
own safety before it was too late.
The doctor politely refused, and enquired
about the Third Brother.
SCP-1440 seemed to describe an elusive figure,
who never appeared to him.
But, the Old Man from Nowhere seemed to imply
that one glimpse of this mysterious Third
Brother would ‘set him free’.
Perhaps he meant by curing his tortured immortality,
or at least making it safe for SCP-1440 to
be around people without causing their destruction.
“The Third never appears.
In that, he is crueler than both his brothers,
for he knows his appearance is the only thing
that will set me free.
I have spent time untold searching for him,
trying to return his prize and those I won
from his brothers, but to no avail.”
SCP-1440 remarked that the Second Brother
had his hands on the doctor’s shoulders,
taking that as an omen of doom and the doctor’s
imminent death.
The Old Man offered one final warning:
“Should you choose to challenge Death to
a game of cards for your life, there is one
thing you must never do…
Win.”
At that precise moment, the nuclear device
kept on site as a failsafe was activated,
bypassing all security protocols and failsafes.
The entire Foundation facility was destroyed,
killing every single member of personnel in
a quick instant of atomic obliteration.
A week later, a figure was spotted over three
thousand kilometers away from the blast site:
an old man, who had suffered no apparent damage
from the explosion or the fallout.
It seems, through his vague allusion to three
brothers and card games, that SCP-1440 gained
his immortality from Death itself.
Or rather, a group of entities known as The
Brothers Death, although they have been referred
to as countless names by cultures past and
present across the world; Old Gods, The All-Death,
Yulu, Yama, Kshitigarbha.
These three brothers are a lot more than just
a trio of grim reapers collecting the souls
of the dead.
They are, in fact, responsible for the creation
of everything that exists as we know it, governing
all of reality and deciding when each part
of it must come to its unavoidable end.
It would appear that, by challenging The Brothers
Death to a card game, SCP-1440 was cursed
with his eternal lifespan, while also causing
the deaths of thousands without choice or
consent.
The items that the Old Man carries are even
the Prizes of the Brothers Death, won during
the same card game.
While limited in their uses, they are extremely
powerful, and can reduce the Brothers’ influence
on the mortal coil.
The glass cup holds the Elixir of Life, a
single drop capable of curing the sickest
of men and saving them from the grip of Death.
The playing cards the Old Man keeps are the
Cards of Fate, holding the power to challenge
Death’s authority and alter fate, preventing
wars, deaths, and calamities.
Finally, the Sack of the All Death, able to
carry anything within it, including unspeakable
catastrophes and even Death itself.
As human populations spread further into previously
uninhabited areas, it’s becoming harder
for SCP-1440 to avoid contact with people.
Drawn to them by his unstoppable compulsion,
he continues to live out century after century
spent causing destruction and death wherever
he wanders to.
Just pray that the old man never finds his
way to your town…
No go check out “SCP-1879 - Indoor Salesman”
and “SCP-2852 Sadistic Madman Party Crasher
| Cousin Johnny” for more strange men you
really don’t want to run into!